But this is something that women and mothers do all the time.
It's the same thing as, like,
oh, I gave birth vaginally,
not C section. I'm a real mom.
You're not. You didn't really get first
that fucking bullshit ass argument
that's just there to try to divide and split women.
Um, the next argument that we all have,
breastfeed or bottle? Oh,
you didn't breastfeed your children?
Breast is best. What do you mean? You gave them four,
as if that fucking matters.
Um, and then the next,
you know, the next,
every debate. Like,
it feels like every decision in motherhood
is just an opportunity for women to tear each other apart,
you know what I mean? When you're dealing with the wrong kind of women,
the women who still don't understand
that we need to fucking stick together
is that same pick me girl spirit
when we're little girls and like,
oh, I'm prettier,
he picked me, I'm skinnier.
Um, and I. Yeah,
I just think it's really shitty.
I, I don't wanna be in a relationship where someone is their stepfather
and I'm giving all this authority to them.
My kids have been through enough.
But I just didn't wanna put my romantic life on pause
because I had children. So the way for me to balance that was to, like,
just kind of have a little village.
Like, he's my boyfriend and they're my kids,
and we all cohabitate and live together,
but he Doesn't really help me a ton.
And that's how I want it.
That's how we are all comfortable.
And, yeah,
I think to say, oh,
you're not a single mom is, um,
really shitty, so. And really untrue.